today's new member of the day is Garrett
Arnie Johnson Garrett thank you for
being a david pakman show member we
depend on funding from viewers and
listeners like Garrett to keep going and
growing please sign up you'll get all
the great member benefits including the
world-famous bonus show earlier this
week on the bonus show we tried vegan
cheese sent to us by a viewer and it was
great all right let's go to your calls
we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 we
will start with our first caller of the
day from the 516 area code caller what's
your name where are you calling from and
you can go ahead and jump right into
your question if you want this is adam
friedman from manhattan and my question
is David if you could handpick anybody
in the country to be the president in
other words out of everybody that you
know scientists doctors if you could
just choose one who would be so honored
by your request immediately serve as
president and give up everything that
they're doing who is this person be this
is a complicated question because on the
one hand I could name someone that we
all might consider sort of in the
political world but the truth is that
our system in the US for picking
politicians is so messed up that the
people who really would be most
competent are people that you and I Adam
have probably never even heard of
because really we we have a system that
only allows certain types of people to
even get into national politics so i
think that i would pick the name I i
guess i would say it's a nameless person
that i think would be the best person to
be President of the United States it's
someone we haven't heard of it might be
a college professor or a scientist or
something like that but I I think the
issue is we don't know actually most of
the people who would be the best in that
role you know what I mean Pat and then a
country of 300 million people if you got
a bunch of these people together each
person would be more impressive than the
next which really goes to the idea that
it was a shame that the best to people
who get in 2016 we're Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton yeah so it does say a
lot about the system so you have do you
have a name in mind
that you would pick ya thinking lawrence
krauss I just heard his podcast on rope
the guy is very impressive yeah he was
also i thought- know but i didn't get a
chance to see that interview yeah one
more question for Pat and then i'll let
you go and what are your thoughts on
dumpster diving for vegans in other
words king that is otherwise about to be
thrown out i guess it would be better
but it's still something that i wouldn't
advocate for you wouldn't help because
the idea of freeganism as opposed to
veganism is that you go and you you know
all of the almost perfect food that gets
thrown out you pull it out of the
dumpster so to speak it reminds me of
fur coats being donated to people who
are homeless and otherwise don't have a
way of keeping themselves warm so I
guess that is certainly better and you
know I don't know if I'm in support of
it but it's a step forward alright we're
going to have Pat do a detailed review
of freeganism and then we will follow up
if he ends up having strong feelings
about it alright thanks so much really
appreciate the call thanks guys all
right take care